skorile Bilder aus Florida in den
USA ein Mann fährt mit seinem weißen
pickup truck über den Strand direkt ins
Wasser eine gute Minute lang pflügt sein
Fahrzeug bei stürmischem Wetter durch
die Wellen was das soll gute Frage die
sich wohl am besten mit weil er es kann
und will beantworten lässt denn einen
wirklich ernsthaften Grund für die
irfahrt scheint es nicht zu
geben anwesende Rettungsschwimmer rufen
schließlich die Polizei nimmt den
49-Jährigen fest ob der Mann unter
Drogen standand oder betrunken war ist
unklar er muss sich jetzt allerdings
wegen einer nicht Bezahlung der
zugangsgebühr für Fahrzeuge verantworten
ja so heißt das offiziell denn das
Autofahren am Strand ist hier
tatsächlich erlaubt wenn man dafür
bezahlt allerdings sollte man sich dafür
vielleicht schöneres Wetter aussuchen an
diesem Tag war der Strand wegen des
Sturms und der hohen Wellen jedenfalls
gesperrt Kommentar eines Augenzeugen das
war das düm was ich je gesehen
habe